Hello, hello.
I was, the past two days, working.
Yes, although it says rest day, or until the next highest,
I'm still working.
There's no stopping with the work.
Oh my god, there's so much behind-the-scenes stuff to do.
Oh, okay, because I'm the boss now I can talk about this
stuff without having to worry about like can I talk about
this?
I'm the boss.
I say I can talk about this.
So like what things?
That was very stressed out about by the way Oh my god,
opening a store and running a store is so hard.
Oh my gosh Because there's a lot of things that can happen
that because we're all starting out my team is just starting
out i'm just starting out running a john ass store like you
know the best i have done was etsy and artist alley so like
um you said rest day you well i didn't say who's gonna be
resting what i might have been implying that you're the one
that's resting not me the thing about being a streamer is
that technically there's no actual rest days When you're a
streamer because you're always working like you give
yourself the rest day Because your your whole job is to
stream and to like keep up your platform your social
platform and all that fucking shit If I was that's why I'm
playing supermarket simulator so I can be like I can be a
real person You know it's not like I'm working at a
supermarket where I just Where I just check in through my
hours and then check out and not have to worry about the
anymore instead as a streamer we always have to worry about
everything stream ends you think we stop working well like
for some people maybe but for me I'm still working because I
have to like make sure that I you know make sure that I
still have a income coming
you don't know that anyway um so you think of a super chat
thank you thank you also then welcome to the tomato farm
welcome welcome okay anyway where was I okay yes anyway
where the store was is incredibly difficult it's such a huge
learning process especially opening up the store to more and
more um to more and more like people from different
countries so one of the biggest issue mistake I found out
yesterday um I was like looking through like uh because like
finally I had time to look through like the orders and the
um the payments and stuff like that and the analytics so I
was looking at the store analytics yesterday and then I
noticed I was like this only applied to the lunar new year
merch by the way so like do not worry about like oh my gosh
Tokyo what were your other mergers are you okay with the
other merch so this only applied to the lunar yeah This is
the pain of being self-employed.
The Lunar New Year merch.
So I was looking and I was like, Oh, okay, someone ordered
the Lunar New Year recloccupied Stand.
So then I was like, all right.
Okay, and then I looked at it and I realized, wait a minute,
why is the stand three dollars shipping?
I was like, that's for stickers.
And then I realized almost everybody that had ordered
individual Lunar New Year stands were paying three dollars
for shipping.
So I was like freaking like okay shipping is not three i
might be trying to make shipping cheaper but it's definitely
not three dollars so now i was like oh my guys what the
happened so there was like a mistake and somehow only the
lunar new year acrylic stand got affected by this thankfully
it's changed now it's changed it was changed yesterday night
when we caught it but like i'm taking the lost because
obviously like we're all still starting out and everything
and so like i don't want to refund that because it was like
um the mistake was on our side and not on the customer side
so like i was like okay it wasn't that bad it was only like
only like 50 people bought the sand so i was like I can tank
50 people.
Like, I get it.
I was just like, it wasn't really a lost, lost.
Like, there's still profits going on.
Just, um, it's just people who individually ordered the
send.
Like, it's just that.
And I was like, it's all right.
It's like, it's just, it's fine.
Like, there's still a profit for it.
It's just, um, you know, regarding that, it's just like,
they, they're still paying for that so I was like it's fine
it's fine I'll just I can I can take the cost for them okay
I it's just the longer I do this the more experience we're
gonna get so I'm it's okay I'm happy to take the mistakes
now then later on because I'll be like okay if it was like
oh my god thank you for the 50 get the chips thank you thank
you masters thank you for 50 good the ships thank you thank
you i really appreciate it but i was like i prefer i'd
rather we make these mistakes now than later down on the
line when it will be a that like if it was a thousand people
then we would have an issue but like now like i'd rather
just take it now than later on down the line so we've
learned our team is learning as we go along building more
and more
I had to I was going through that but it's okay like we
we're not really we're not losing money in the end even
though that happened we're not losing money it's just that
like regarding that it's just not like as much profit versus
the other if we if this shipping was like the right cost
like like it's just a couple of dollars like the shipping
because like normally the shipping would be like seven to
eight dollars instead of three so like i was like okay
that's fine that's fine like i'm willing to tank that and it
wasn't that big of an amount so um robin thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you yeah i was like it wasn't a
thousand i'm Okay, it didn't even hit a hundred.
It only it was two digits.
It's fine So I was doing I was handling I was having that
because I was like thinking this is a learning experience
for for the team and I Having a store is like one of the
hardest I think like our everything the store is definitely
the hardest thing to to deal to deal with because like
Obviously there's like so many factors and then like also
like the currency the currency like converting and
everything um and it's just oh my god it is it's a lot it's
a lot yeah so i hope that like like i get like my team and i
get better and better as it is as we go along oh my and also
like i have a like i have a meeting with my accountant and
then also like lawyer for like regarding like drafting up
contracts and stuff like uh we we are we're working on an
nda contract for like people we hire and everything and i
was like oh my god i just i just want to stream funny games
i just i was like i just want to stream silly games like
supermarket simulator
oh my god yeah i was like i need like like my mr man and my
mom was like you need to have they're like did you let these
did you're any of the artists you hired inside any is i was
like no i'm an indie and like no dokey we need the for your
safety we need to have these contracts Guys!
I was like, I'm trying!
We need to protect yourself!
I was like, I know!
I just...
I know!
I'm doing my best!
So yeah, anyway...
Anyway, I was like, Dealing with a lot of the work stuff for
that.
So, so being my own boss is a lot.
It's definitely a lot of stuff going on.
There's been a lot of meetings I had to attend.
A lot of meetings I had to attend.
A lot of like contracts I had to sign.
A lot.
I was just like, oh my God.
But I can also delegate my work too.
So, like, I'm not doing everything myself.
I delegate it to other people.
So, I'd be like, you do that.
And you do that.
So, like, at best, I don't even have to attend that many
meetings.
Because, like, the, like, my team attends a lot of my
meetings, too.
And then they just, like, tell me what's going on.
And I'm like, that's great.
I'm just, like, thank fucking God.
Thank God.
Oh, yeah.
Um, um.
Um, another little bit of announcement.
Um, I got invited to do a, uh, uh, I don't know when this is
going to be.
It's not this week, by the way, but I got invited to do a JP
Apex tournament.
I don't know when, I don't remember when it's going to be.
It's not this week.
That's, it's not, that's not the special Apex stream, by the
way.
That's not the Apex special stream.
It's a different one.
So, are we participating in Japanese Apex tournament?
in the nearby future.
I don't remember what the date it is.
I should write stuff down.
I really should.
And then the collab with Amali on Saturday.
I saw people were like, who is it going to be, Doki?
Who are you going to play with?
The two other people?
I don't even know because we haven't asked anybody.
I put that down.
People think that I put it down because we don't we haven't
asked who the two people are we haven't even asked people
yet because I was just like I just want to put my schedule
up I just want to put my schedule up so I was just like I
was just like I just love how everyone's like oh my god it's
I wonder if it's these guys I was like I don't know me too I
don't even know who they are gonna be too
whoa um it's a surprise for everyone me.
Alright, let's actually play supermarket simulator.
Let's go.
I love, I was like reading the, like, what's upcoming and I
love how cleaning's there.
And I was like, oh, thank God I'm playing.
I'm playing God they haven't pushed out the cleaning update
yet.
I really, really don't want to clean.
So I was like, oh, thank God.
That's like, that's like one thing.
I'm glad it's not in there.
So, oh my gosh, shoplifters, security guard, CCTV.
Oh my God, this is going to be like too real why why work at
your local supermarket well you can play like a supermarket
simulator bigger city to travel around veggie and fruits
weighing them this buying a i don't need a house i can live
in this supermarket the supermarket has everything i need
just like that mr beast video where like that couple lived
in the supermarket for a fucking month or some shit guys
thank you create a code for fortnite in the future my v bugs
you're going to be spent um yes in the future there's like
some stuff going on around that because i'm trying to
transfer see figure out a way to transfer my my skins to my
throat keeper i'm just trying to figure out if there is any
way to do that because i spent around like almost like 600
plus dollars on fortnite skins because i have a problem
regarding fortnite skins so like um, but But i would say
that whatever creator code you're using It still works
The money for that code still goes to me.
I'll just say that that's all i can say That's all I can say
So until then You can keep using whatever code you have Okay
Anton Thank you for the super chat Thank you Thank you Gotta
get the hey Peter skin Thank you for the super chat Thank
you Thank you So like that's all I can say about that The
reason why we don't have a new code yet Is because I'm
trying to get my fucking Fortnite skins back So the moment I
can get my skin back there will be a new code because I
don't give a fuck about anything else on that account I just
want my fort I need you guys to know like when I didn't have
a job that time I bought more fortnight skins as retail
therapy and I have a John Cena skin on there and I swear to
God I need those skins back I spent so much Money!
I need all the skin!
I spent so much money.
I bought so many.
I bought a lot.
I don't even have a John Cena skin on there now.
I have the, what was it?
The perfect cell of skin because I thought I would be funny
with the basketball.
And I, I need them.
I need them back.
Mr. Mads working on it.
Mr. Mads said it's possible to get my skins back.
That's all I want.
Last order.
Thank you for the 10 gift dishes.
Thank you.
Oh no, chair.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Thank John Cena's skin is so opiate.
Nobody can see you.
All right, let's play the actual supermarket.
All right.
Welcome to the supermarket.
You'll start with a small store and grow to an awesome
supermarket.
I'm gonna be whole was it whole greens?
Was that super expensive like a suburban mom supermarket?
I want to be that I want Everything is like times three
expensive whole foods.
I want to be whole foods We're gonna be the better whole
foods start by pushing goods to sell and place them onto
shelves Don't forget to set prices to avoid a profit with
profit to avoid bank.
I can do that.
Oh my god that's all right let's turn now let's do all it's
only hot where's my ultra ultra setting for this game order
using the computer uh all right okay market uh we're gonna
have cereal how much money i have how much money okay we
have 50 not a lot to start a supermarket okay we're not
gonna have cereal cereal is not not a lot not a lot of
people that awaken them no actually we start with cereal
because the people who are awake this early that need cereal
have money actually know their students never mind fucking
no moms moms will buy moms will need cereal for their
children and we all know if the moms have kids okay usually
then they can afford good ass cereal all right okay we're
gonna have cereal all right and then everybody loves pasta
who doesn't love pasta all right This is gonna be our store.
We're just we're just gonna have cereal and pasta.
That's fine Mom's need to cook too.
They need to cook Okay, they need cereal and pasta.
All right, how do I show?
Okay All right, nice.
Here's my pasta.
There's my is that cereal pasta.
There's my pasta and then Nexi, thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you.
Can I get my...
No, white!
Okay, I'm not very good at shelving.
Okay, give me a sec.
Sorry.
I'm new here.
This is my store, and I'm new here.
Next thing, thank you.
The magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, set the price.
Okay.
Market price is...
Nine...
Zero point.
Okay, two.
Two.
Wait, market price is 312?
Then it should be four, right?
Four...
no no we should be five dollars five ninety nine five ninety
nine nothing nothing ever goes wrong with five ninety nine
okay market prices that's some expensive cereal is cereal
that expensive i've had cereal in in years guys ever since i
stopped going to school thank you um talk i think it was a
super chat thank you thank you i hope she made lots of get
there's no way there is no way cereal is that expensive now
did inflation fucked up that hard are we are we in the bad
type of inflation now all inflation is bad by the way dude
what 899 is like common for cereal are you see are you are
you guys 899 bro it doesn't come with toys anymore.
They don't even come with toys.
Cera's over $10.
We're at a lift.
Bro.
You know what?
Maybe capitalism is a bad idea.
Hello, sir.
Will you buy my $8.99 cereal?
Oh, my God.
Pass that's too expensive.
You bought the cereal.
Alright.
giving zero dollars there's nothing to give how do i approve
insufficient there's zero dollars oh wait 91 wait you gave
me a hundred dollars for your fucking cereal okay 60 70 80
91 here there we go i can't believe it this man gave a
hundred $100.
No, I have to do math.
Okay.
I can't believe this is too expensive.
I can't believe it.
It says market price is $3.
Like $3.12.
This should have been fine.
Okay.
Boop.
Ooh, credit card.
Oh, thank God.
8.99.
Yay!
How's the past?
It's too expensive!
I don't know.
I don't understand.
Okay.
Okay, fine.
I'll lower it.
I'm going to lower it to 59 cents.
All right.
There.
And this is the guy who he thought the zero was 100 bucks.
Many thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
I don't understand.
How could it be like expensive?
I need money.
This is fucked up.
This is so fucked up.
All right.
storage.
Wait, I want to rename my store.
I want me to rename it to Better Whole Foods.
I can't believe it.
Oh, I could have... I could take a loan.
It is.
It's still too expensive!
Fine!
Five.
Okay.
Four dollars.
Is that fine?
Fine.
Four dollars.
No, that's way too cheap, man.
Four four.
food 450 take it or leave it oh she took it she did take it
nice okay 36 uh 5151 quick mass we're doing it we found the
perfect center we found Can't thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What?
You don't want pasta and cereal.
What do you mean you don't want pasta and cereal?
It's the perfect combination for your day.
It's literally breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
I give you breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
This is a mass simulator.
I gave her more than her change?
No.
The pasta is still too expensive this is good pasta this is
what do you mean Amy thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you weirdo thank you for the five gifted chips thank
you thank you it's like the good type of pasta yeah this man
can afford quality life for his children all right nice okay
two one here you go
makes it 39 oh that's true 399 what a fucking steal that man
knows he caught economics 399
there you go we're doing it the 399 is this where we do
we're doing it we're doing it
running a successful store oh my god seriously expensive you
don't deserve the cereal ma'am come back when you have the
money for this sick-ass chuckle chucky pick bear cereal
strong chocolate okay maybe this is a bit too much chocolate
this is better whole foods come back when you can afford to
take care your children with gourmet cereal how is that
still too expensive okay what about 98 98 we gotta like
oversell to make money five six one there yeah easy
come how are you still too expensive i don't understand i
don't extend All right.
My store is not...
My store is, like, good for everybody.
Create more change.
All right.
Okay, how about 97?
Maybe 97.
I'm going to...
We're going to find a sweet spot.
All right.
One cent.
There you go.
Oh, wait.
You can take your money back, but right...
Okay.
That's one dollar.
No.
Okay, I was gonna be like, I almost gave them one dollar.
Guys, guys, I'm learning.
I'm learning to be the best cashier.
Why is it still too expensive?
First it was pasta, now it's cereal.
Okay, 50.
It has to be good.
It has to be the sweet spot.
All right, let's see.
How much was it?
$3.99, cereal.
ma'am are you looking for some cereal for your children ah
that's right you know the good life your chill this cereal
and pasta will make your children so fucking smart trust me
this is like certified dokey dokey ah yes rich lady are you
here to make sure your children are eating well you don't
love your kids
maybe all right we need more pasta there we go yay all right
at least my pasta's selling now yay
are they still too expensive i have lights no we don't need
electricity i don't want to wait wait okay i need to look at
the electricity bill do we have to pay electricity bill no
okay not We can have electricity for now.
I need to know.
I need to know how much electricity is.
All right, fine.
Three.
Okay, wait, nope.
It was a cereal, right?
Why is cereal so expensive for you?
This is market price.
This is actually market price cereal.
Okay, fine.
We're going $8, guys.
We're having a cereal sale.
Serious.
Oh, food's in dark mode.
Serial sale.
time oh my god look at they see a good bargain they know
that's a good bargain 3.99 nice thank you oh and you get
okay i thought they gave me exact change there you go guys
cereal sale guys guys it's 9 p.m cereal sale cereal sale
guys we have a great deal for all of you
James Moore, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you, be like a real store, slap a 50% discount sign, but
still selling at price, price, profit 10 out of 10, also
milk and sauce for the cereal and pasta, oh my god, you guys
are so fucking smart, it's like you guys own, you guys have
owned like cereal stores before, also give me a sec, let me
pull up my cereal.
so I can look at super chat easier.
Okay, so I don't have to scroll up for super chats real
fast.
All right, here we go.
We got end of the day.
All right.
Products found expensive 17.
Oh, yeah, I don't need you 17 people.
I have eight customers that can afford my bougie cereal.
They care about their kids.
They care about the well-being of their children.
All right.
income i have a 56 profit yay trying to give us a super chat
thank you thank you oh man if i step in this shop with this
selection i will feel bad not buying anything exactly no
receipt no or they'll be paid automatically the more
electrical devices what if i don't turn the lights on i'll
just never turn on the lights that's fucked up that's so
fucked up i'll just never turn on the lights so i'll never
have to pay bills if there's no electricity okay we need
bread now people would want bread for with their food bread
and oil to cook pasta there we go we're going doing it All
right, let's see.
Wait, okay, here you go.
All right, now we have oil for the pasta.
We love pasta with just oil.
And then bread.
Oh, shit.
Bread.
All right, this is good shelving right there.
You know what?
No, no, no, no.
This is optimal shelving.
All right, let's see.
What's the market price for bread?
five dollars this is like bread made by one baker in a small
village in Italy that's when you know it's good bread oh
5.99 so it looks cheaper 5.99 oil all right 450 is the
market price 6.99 there we go there we go that's good that's
a good bread this bread this bread chat was made by an
80-year-old grandma in Italy.
That's when you know it's good bread.
This oil is peanut oil from the forest of Madagascar.
That's when you know it's good peanut oil.
And we're open for business.
If you don't buy any of my products, you don't love your
children enough.
chat thank you thank you conserving energy like this is five
nights at donkeys thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you you scam it is imported how dare you call me
scammer this is imported peanut oil from madagascar that's a
supermarket slogan i can get bought it's like i'll Take $10
worth of bread, please.
Liz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sir, how dare you not love your children?
You only give the pasta without the oil?
What is wrong with you?
I can't.
This, by the way, the grandma's name is Braun, by the way.
I can't believe it.
What would grandma run?
What the fucking night?
Bro, carry some fucking change.
What's wrong with you?
All right, here you go.
All right.
Who carries cash anymore?
Okay, fine.
Grandma run.
We'll not be happy about this.
Does someone really say this is Madagascar a movie?
It's based off a play.
actual place.
It's an actual country.
Okay.
13.5.
All right.
There you go.
This woman loves their children enough.
All right.
Guys.
Buy my.
Oh my God.
My.
Okay.
We need to order more.
We need to order more cereal.
Or cereal.
Actually going off the shelves right now.
All right.
Boop.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
No change.
Uh.
Card.
All right.
Uh.
Eight.
Nice.
Okay, we gotta stock, restock our cereal.
Can I thank you for the Super Chat?
Thank you, thank you.
One cereal, please.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Ivy, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki's Whole Foods model.
If you don't buy my products, you don't love your children.
Exactly.
This is like, these products, these important bread and oil,
it will make your kids so fucking smart okay for 50 there's
a 50 cents now when the fuck was there a 50 cents has there
always been a 50 wait what do you say was too expensive what
do you say when you don't have kids then you're not thinking
about your future you don't you you need to have kids so you
can you can buy my products have children so they can buy my
products and also subscribe to me on the youtube's that is
important okay one there we go thank you for buying my stuff
um bread is bread here's 10 more dollars to take it but oil
is too expensive okay okay what okay fine we'll do six
dollars are you happy now are you happy now janice are you
fucking happy now i have to pay okay Doki's whole food needs
to survive.
Are you happy about ruining small business?
You're the reason why small businesses don't prosper.
Okay, let's see.
19.99.
Oh, Oh my god, you love your children!
Sir, I'm so happy for you.
Guys, this is...
Guys, guys, support local businesses.
Please, support local businesses.
Guys, I'm almost done my objective.
Please buy my products.
This is so fucked.
Imagine like a store manager's be like, please buy my
products.
Please, please.
You look like a lady.
who needs cereal you need some cereal ma'am oh my god she
bought two bread and it's oil oh my god she's gonna make a
grilled cheese all right nice okay money oh and she pays an
exact change i love her she's what every business wants
wings thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
treating kids like a costco remember the super chat thank
you thank you one two three ta-da i'm making so much money
now look at me i'm 164 dollars she love her kids all right
nice eight dollars oh my god i'm getting better at math oil
is too expensive you are never meant to be in my store oh
but you bought too serious so that's okay that's more money
never mind welcome back sir i hope you enjoy your stay
purchase product license for what what do i need product
license for i have everything i've ever wanted cereal bread
and pasta and oil
extreme thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm
sorry i was trying to get the pickles back and lock it over
the pickled display in aisle six but i'm covering in pickle
juice And the entire store smells like pickles.
I hope this covers the cost.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can't afford my pasta.
Go back and buy macaroni and cheese.
Which I love macaroni and cheese, by the way.
No hate on macaroni and cheese.
But this is bougie pasta.
All right.
We're not turning on the lights because I need to save
electricity.
I need...
Guys!
We need to save electricity.
We don't need lights.
we don't need lights guys guys this is important we are a
small local business what do you think?
Do you think we're actual whole foods?
We're not we're better whole foods but we're not at the
better yet okay wait I'm so poor I can't afford any product
license my favorite girl cheese without the cheese it's okay
I can defend my store In the dark Alright, nice What do you,
okay, cash One dollar, oh I like you sir Nice, alright Card
Um Six dollars We're half foods, we're half foods We're not
at the whole food section Yet guys, we're merely in the Half
food section One day We'll be like whole foods A hundred
dollar profit Nice.
All right.
Do I have to pay any bills yet?
Bank.
Okay, no, we're not getting a loan.
Bills.
But see, look at that.
Look at that, chat.
I didn't turn on the lights and only 52 cents.
That is how you save money.
That is exactly how you save money.
Why use lights?
My phone can produce lights.
guys my phone produces light so why the fuck would i need
any electricity if i can't see anything i take up my phone
sounds like my dad it is called being a small business
trying to survive in the harsh world okay do i i don't have
the level yet all right Oh, we need to restock.
We need to restock on our imported peanut oil.
All right, where is product?
Oops.
Okay, oil.
All right, we just need oil.
That's fine.
Yes, Mr. Crab.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but Mr. Crab's a fucking millionaire.
Look, I will be...
Mr. Crab's is a role model.
He is a cutthroat business crab.
He knows what it's like.
He has a whale daughter to fucking care for.
Do you know how much whales eat?
Okay, let's see.
$16.
Whales eat a lot of food.
And then he has to pay for college tuition.
I like money.
He likes money.
We all like money here.
God, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
We need cereal.
We need to make sure for the cereal demand.
Don't worry.
I will make sure the demand is met.
Oh, my God.
No, ma'am.
Do not buy anything.
The cereal is coming.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Wait.
She didn't buy anything.
What?
You don't love your children.
you don't like your kids what's your husband gonna think um
cosmic thank you for the super chat thank you thank you many
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you the stokey
grass remember her first dollar thank you the super chat
thank you thank you all right let's see six all right i
can't believe it you're willing to buy expensive bread but
not expensive cereal oh my god this bread is more expensive
than the fucking cereal like what the fuck remind actually
never mind five dollar profit oh yeah super thank you for
the super chat thing there's no chance that mr crabs is
paying for anyone's okay there's no chance in hell pearl is
smart enough for a spot a scholarship that's right i said it
i said it there's no way pearl can have a skull can get a
scholarship that's sucking right She has to be able to
afford her college.
Don't do her like that.
What?
How is she going to get to college?
The cheerleading?
Oh, yeah.
As if, like, yeah.
There's like how many people in Bikini Bottom.
How many people in Bikini Bottom?
I don't think they're giving us scholarships for a fucking
cheerleading.
yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you one
zero please keep the change that is a good customer hello
why do i have to give you would you like to give a tip for a
um for a small business woman in your for your local
businesses i don't have a tip jar i should have a tip jar
and whole foods might not have a tip jar but half foods does
oh oh a 220 $12.
I'm level 13.
Oh, I'm level 3.
I can buy a product.
Okay, what can I sell?
Bottled water.
Guys, guys.
Evian water's coming in hot now.
Guys.
Oh my god, this is it.
We're in the big leagues now.
We have bottled water.
We're moving up.
We're not just gonna be half foods.
Okay, how much is bottled water?
Okay, bottled water is $15.
I can afford bottled water.
Oh my god, we're actually in the big leagues.
Oh my god, we have water!
Boop.
Wait, this product, wait, what?
I need to be put on a fridge!
God damn it.
Okay guys, we're not in the big leagues yet.
I can't afford a fridge.
That's like electricity.
Who wants cold water?
Put it in the fridge yourself.
Who the fuck wants cold water?
I don't understand.
Okay, we need more bread.
We need to sell.
Room temperature water is just fine.
Room temperature water is good enough.
Oh, shit.
Incorrect, payment.
Who cares?
Okay, 5.5.
Nice.
Okay.
Cool.
Card.
Nice.
card is nice because I don't have to worry about uh all
right I don't have to worry about math I can just put
numbers down okay cereal bread I don't I can't afford a
fridge what do you mean fridge it's 200 oh my god I'm not
made of money it's 30 250 cereal a name sorry to get the
super chat.
Thank you.
Remind that Mr. Krabs make Spundrapped pay to work at the
Krusty Krab.
Oh my God.
Guys, the ones to work for one Akasupa, you can have the
privilege to work in my store for a day.
It's like an internship, guys.
Think about like the amazing reference I can work.
I can write for you.
Guys, just think about it think about the amazing reference
you're gonna get if you work at half foods what a deal also
it's like one akad day though by the way it's one akad day
just so you guys know um the south views thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you who wants avian water when
you can buy locally sourced avian tap water bottle by the
local kids for free only a hundred dollars Thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Zappies.
Now somebody is taking business.
That's a good business owner right there.
3.99.
There we go.
Let's say this is the nighttime experience.
The only store that's in the dark.
We have to save on electricity.
We're not made of money.
The only reason we're in the dark is because it's your
fault, customers.
you don't pay you don't buy my stuff enough
what you do thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
for the akasupa thank you thank you i'm here for my shift oh
i got oh thank god all right so anyway i'll just be like the
supervisor now uh arsenic thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you thank you what minus 84 profit Oh my god.
Thank God for my free interns.
Uh, I need the references for my resume.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God for my free interns.
Oh, I don't have enough for anything.
Okay, we need more oil.
All right, oil.
There you go.
Purchase.
Uh, Loretta, thank you for the aqua soup.
Thank you.
So when is my first day right now?
stock these shows for me i wish this has like if only this
has like twitch plays supermarket simulator so i can like
actually hire my viewers
you know like those like the call of the lamb where you can
get viewer participation man if only i can get viewer
participation the multiplayer store ready and i could just
sit here and order item.
Oh, shit.
What are the bills?
Do I have to pay any bills?
Bills.
Rent?
I paid for rent.
$20 a day?
That's like a scam.
I'm just a small business.
The $20 is like one peanut oil.
Boom.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
Do we get cool name tags?
Guys, with enough Akas, we can afford one cashier.
Guys, you see, daily wage is...
You guys pay me $80.
Guys, with enough Akas, we can finally afford a cashier.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
All right.
Oh, we need pasta.
Pasta.
Where's pasta?
All right.
Pasta.
Guys, I need $200, guys.
4.
Oh, whoops.
Nice.
I can leave 50 checkouts!
Oh my gosh, I'm doing it.
I'm being the wagey I've always wanted to be.
Where's my pasta?
Okay, pasta.
Alright.
We don't care about your fucking opinion, Annie.
You spent less on that fucking...
You spent less on...
On, okay, you clearly need sunscreen.
If you spend less at the hair salon, maybe you can afford.
Granny Ron's bread.
Now your family's gonna be breadless.
You can clearly afford fucking bread.
If you only have $100 bills, you can totally afford bread.
You're just a cheapskate.
I hope your kids hate you.
nice she gave you a hundred all right nice 106 guys I need a
hundred dollars anybody want to shop and have food look chat
you don't understand the supermarket game is very scary the
supermarket game is very intense guys you don't understand
okay You'll never understand the life of a supermarket
boner.
Doki, calm down.
I can't calm down.
She criticized my pasta and bread.
That grandma in Italy needs that money.
Cali intensifies.
Guys, think about Granny Ron.
Won't anybody think about Granny Ron from Italy?
She cares about Granny Ron.
She cares so much about her Granny Ron.
She gave me $250.
Five, six, seven, eight, nine.
There you go.
Thank you for shopping at Half Foods.
Ron sliced bread is too expensive.
What did you buy?
You buy two cereals and zero bread?
It's like almost the same.
It's almost the same.
Put in some checkout account and then you won't even have to
pay.
Brank you're so smart we can let techno AI can finally steal
everybody's work oh my god oh my god finally the AI uprising
we needed they started out small first to check out cashiers
then the world the Walmart approach it's actually scary
though like like now is there's like some some McDonald's
that are only run by like a like by like uh self-checkout
like everything is just like automated i remember reading an
article about that that there's like mcdonald restaurants
that are just fully automated like even like taking orders
and everything for yeah like making food and taking orders
and giving orders and stuff i don't know i think it has to
be in america it's only somebody in America would do
something like that.
Oh, that's Syria.
Everybody loves Syria.
Okay.
All right.
Grab that Syria.
Someone's like, we have those in New York City.
They suck.
Money.
50 cents.
There you go.
You love bread.
Thank you for supporting your local granny uh 31 nice i
can't wait for the ai takeover it gives me more time
cam you have all the time but we're the money to you cam you
forgot the money if all the robots take over all the jobs
how do we make money Who would give you the money to keep
working?
That makes me keep working.
To do whatever you want.
Alright, nice.
Where's the tomatoes?
Tomatoes cost a fridge.
Does it look like I have the money for fridge?
Okay, we need more.
Okay, nice.
I can finally afford.
I can afford a fridge.
Oh my god.
Okay, fridge time.
Fridge A.
Yeah, all right, $200.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where's my fridge?
Oh my god.
Sir, please wait a little bit.
I'm putting a fridge.
Okay.
Nice exact bills.
I love that.
Uh, $1.
Nice.
Okay.
We can finally put our expensive avian water.
yay all right what do you want would you like to buy our
expensive avian water real fast before you do no it's all
right it's all right all right just my water okay how much
for water two five dollars this is like this is not amazon
99 cents shit oh no no not zero dollars oh there's more
people coming in oh nice uh uh 27 sorry i couldn't see that
you used your card did you buy water was water too expensive
oh you don't want basic necessities sir that's bg water
right there that's not regular water this is from a fucking
island I think $5 is perfect.
What a deal.
Nuki, stop.
Sir, it's good water, sir.
Dio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nuki, I need you to do a Costco live stream ASAP.
I need a stream of you walking around Costco and picking out
your favorite Kirtland product.
Costco sponsor
Super chat thank you thank you guys it's because I bought a
fridge okay I had to I need a okay you know what I'm gonna
make my entire fridge just just water this is okay no water
and milk wait okay what do you guys okay cheese cheese bread
pasta Now we're thinking supermarket owner.
Cheese for the pasta.
Wait, we're running out of stuff.
Okay.
We need pasta.
Okay, let's just stock up everything for now.
We have the money.
If we have everything we need to stock up, we don't have to
worry about anything.
Okay, we're going to put this away.
Oh my gosh.
Our store is becoming so big now.
We're getting closer to closer.
to like uh three-fourths of food okay what's after half
foods what's two quarters food what's after half foods guys
don't put cheese it needs to be in the fridge god damn it we
don't want cold cheese food temperature room temperature
cheese is okay guys sometimes you have to settle settle for
it.
Oh, I'm too poor for eggs.
I'm too poor for eggs.
Okay, I can't afford milk, though.
Alright.
I'm gonna fully stock up.
They'll get mold.
That's the point of cheese!
Good cheese has mold!
This is what?
This is called... This is half foods.
You guys don't understand.
Good cheese has mold.
Toki, no.
You just don't understand good marketing.
Toki, please.
Alright, nice.
We're open.
I forgot to buy oil.
I don't have oil.
No!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't have enough money for tomatoes.
Look.
I can only do it.
There's cake.
There's chicken.
Where the fuck is the fruit section?
There's cleaner chips.
There's beer.
Oh my god.
Guys, we need 3,500.
Guys, why can't the bank give me a loan for beer?
There's books, but there's no fruit?
What is my store?
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, $16.
Alright.
Money.
Oh, okay.
$8.
we're getting better at this we're getting oh god okay i can
afford oil now uh oil nice okay this is good this is good no
it's wrong wrong shelf wait what shelf was it is this one
okay i need a better shelving system guys i need a better
shelving system i already forgot where it was guys guys does
anyone shop oh my god you have money you're wearing a tuxedo
you want my the peanut oil look hey this is new here cheese
is too expensive water is too expensive god okay 4.99 there
we go they don't know they're not culture enough 4.99 there
you go why is my water so expensive it's from an island it's
literally from an island where are my like where am i like
jack blacks and and tom hanks where are they they can afford
my water they care
all right 450 fine i'll go 450 but that's the lowest i'll go
that's the lowest i'll go 450 i'll take the two dollar
profit um round duck thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i will never change the oil my peanut oil from
madagascar um it has too deep and bitter of a flavor thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you 449 you're right
449 when they see the nine they know it's a steal 449 oh my
god you guys are good business people good business goons
Milk is too expensive?
Oh my god.
Why is everything too expensive for all of you?
If you guys think everything is too expensive, you would not
have gone to Half Foods.
Whole Foods is like right next door.
You know what you were expecting in Half Foods.
It might not have been a good business choice to be right
next to Whole Foods.
But it was the cheapest place.
the rents 3.48 God damn it fine fine I'll go down to 4.2 I'm
willing to haggle it's 4.2 now welcome to quarter foods guys
guys you'll regret this I'll remember all your faces you'll
regret not buying from my store when i become big
see she likes the cheese okay 95 dollars jesus christ she
likes the cheese too if you love cheese so much why didn't
you buy more please support your local businesses
fine 10 cents the lowest i'll go
It doesn't even have mud because they won't let me put it
room temperature.
I can't believe it.
Wait, do I have to pay my bills?
I might have forgot about my bills.
Oh, shit.
Oh, 0.49.
Nice.
Okay, 20.
Alright, that's fine.
Nice.
Do you like my water?
Is bottle water good enough?
Is it good enough?
Oh, it's good enough.
Come on.
Couldn't find...
What do you mean you want coffee?
ma'am we don't have a lot of things in the store okay four
nice all right what do you want oh syrup and pasta you're
gonna have a fun night sir it's gonna be so fun okay all
right let's see fine i am willing to go 5.99 on the oil
this but i'm willing to go for for this bargain all right
we're having a sale guys an oil sale grab your oils never
before seen such a deal never before seen oil sale before
grab it before it's gone
someone say oil nice i'm glad this person oh look at that he
heard about the sale he heard about the oil sale good for
you why is my water always too expensive i don't understand
this is like perfectly priced water okay 4.10 that's the
lowest i'll go for cheese for my imported from france cheese
all right hello ma'am slice bread you don't deserve ron
slice bread you don't deserve it you can't you don't deserve
to be in my store never come back yeah oh my god he heard
about the oil sale so where did you hear about the oil sale
uh from your family friends uh website sponsors uh Facebook?
We don't need lighting.
We don't need it.
We're here to save money.
We need to save money to make money.
This is like an exclusive experience that you can only get
at Halfwoods.
Whole Foods is wasting.
Imagine all the electricity Whole Foods is wasting right now
by turning on their lights.
Oh my God!
guys i told you tell your friends tell your friends our oil
is one cent cheaper tell your friends
one set is all it took it truly is oh whoops uh 90 oh there
nice we did it i want those said hey if it works it works
guys look at that and now look at that profit a hundred and
fourteen i don't want to lose oh eggs are now worse now
that's okay we don't need eggs anyway we need more oil the
oil this the oil boom guys the oil boom it's rising all
right back in you go We don't care.
Those 22 people, they don't matter.
We're here to build a customer base that can afford my
products.
Okay, let's see.
We're going to grab some flour for the, I guess, like the
cereal.
We love putting flour on the cereal.
All right, let's put them up here.
All right, this should be good.
And then we're going to put that away.
Alright, how much should the flower be?
Okay, $5.
Is that good profit?
That's a good profit.
Okay, $4.99.
$4.99.
There you go.
So now you know it's a good sale.
No, no, I'm going to put $5.
And then I'm going to lower it to...
And then I'm going to lower it to $4.99.
And so then they'll think it's a sale.
They'll be like, damn, that flower is too expensive.
And I'll be like, I'll be like, oh my god, good thing for
you.
We have a sale going on now.
We have a sale going on.
Now every flower is $4.90.
Hey, if it worked for oil, it can work for flower.
It's not mutually exclusive.
Come to my store.
YT, thank you for the super chat.
I'm an oil man don't keep playing for you thank you in the
super chat ma'am have you heard about our oil sale ma'am are
you gonna buy the we have zero purchases on the water ma'am
it's literally $3.99 don't you need all milk can I suggest
you um people who buy the milk also bought the cereal would
you like to have this in the car
So I will thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Welcome to the tomatoes.
Tomatoes.
Welcome.
40.
Okay.
No.
1, 2, 3, 4.
50.
The Amazon recommendation.
Amazon at Uber Eats recommendation.
4.1.
There we go.
Gotta pay the bills later.
Ma'am.
Where you at?
The cereal?
Ma'am.
you know what's cheaper milk would you like the milk oh the
cheese oh you're a cheese girl i see what the fuck were you
gonna do with cereal and cheese i'll never know okay oh and
you pay exact you clearly only had budget for cheese uh we
need more cheese it's working guys one day somebody will buy
my water oh my god it's working it's the cheese Boom!
Guys, guys, you gotta...
Quick, quick, guys!
It's a cheese boom!
Oil is yesterday's news.
Today is all about the cheese.
$2.
Hello, sir.
The milk?
Okay.
Okay, I need to...
Guys, I've been holding on to this water for two days now.
I don't understand why people do not want...
Okay, what about 3.59?
There we go.
Someone's.
Please.
It's a basic necessity.
Please purchase your water.
Sir, are you going to buy water?
Please, why?
Please, I know it's the cheese boom, sir.
Why is water still too expensive?
Fine.
$3.
That's my final price.
I can't believe it.
Why does no one want my water?
Water is like... Like, you don't need milk guys you don't
need cheese you don't need cheese it's because it's no not
the sunny no not the sunny cheese not the sunny water one
cent here you go water would you like oh my cheese he bought
cheese never mind he did not guys he did not buy water he
did not buy water okay 20.1 yay we got 26 wait what am i
gonna save for now okay we can clearly buy um okay i'm gonna
how much is okay checkout counter spotlight okay i want to
be able to afford a Give me a sec.
Oh my god.
Can't you be patient?
I'm trying to see if I can afford a worker.
Okay, Bills 490.
I need to be level 10.
I'm just level 5.
Okay, we need level 10.
Okay, we can afford this.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
thank you to be fair you are to escape for that price of
water this is reasonably priced water guys i say as i uncap
my fiji water right now
thank you
oh all i had to do was drink fiji water in front of my water
fridge to do i figured it out okay four there you go i
figured it out guys 84 okay uh one two three four well one
two there you go okay we need more we need flour please give
me a sec ma'am we need flour uh pasta okay Boop, boop, boop,
boop.
Okay, $21.
Please.
I need to restock my store.
Pasta.
Pasta's going off the shelves right now.
We're making so much money off of pasta.
And then flour.
All right.
Nice, all right.
I'll never lower my prices.
You can't make me.
Except for water.
I will do that for wine.
me guys my water has been in the store a little bit too long
now okay where's the card okay i grabbed the card guys i
will figure out how i will have night vision soon eventually
i'll unlock night vision no i need to save money
i will never turn on the lights my customer clearly are fine
with it they're fine it's like immersive also like using
your card for like a purchase for four dollars is one it's
like that's dumb because there's like hidden fees and stuff
i don't like using my cards for for like stuff that's less
than like 10 because of the fees you can get from that uh
nice 182 182 dollars that's right all of you guys were
yelling at me to lower my prices but look at the money i
made from that oh cheese cheese is flying off the shells
right now cheese pasta okay we have enough all right here
you uh nice all right cheese cheese we don't need oh wait we
can pot uh throw i can't throw but i'm gonna put the cheese
here we have enough oil we need cereal we need we started
off with cereal our cereal is our biggest money maker cereal
and oil all right let's see i think we're ready we're ready
no i'm gonna order more pasta pasta's been doing well too
time oh my gosh i'm gonna make my first one thousand dollars
this is it guys where were you when joki made her first
thousand dollars we're double thank you thank you thank you
geez the people that come in after sundown be struggling to
see those shows that's good that means they don't know what
they're paying for it's like a little game it's like a
little game guys they don't know like more fun it's it's
guys it's more fun it's like a and like maybe they'll
accidentally you know they'll accidentally um pay buy more
than they actually wanted you know all right milk time okay
7.98 there you go all right how much should i okay market is
okay then that Alright.
Hello, ma'am.
Did you enjoy your stay here at Half Foods?
Uh, 75.
85.
There you go.
That's fine.
It's too expensive?
It's literally at 5.
Okay, wait.
Maybe if I do 11.99.
Guys, coffee on sale.
Coffee on sale.
We're having our biggest sell yet, everybody.
Or...
Our biggest sell yet.
More than 1% off.
Great value.
Well, we need milk.
Milk time.
Okay.
Uh...
nice okay we need restock where the fuck are my interns wait
is this the right one no it was like right here and now i
can put more down there where the fuck are my interns the
one that paid to work for me all right let's see 5.5 oh sir
oh the oil good purchase good purchase you must have
and well guys i don't understand why does anyone want my
coffee there's a huge sale going on
guys big sale big sale we're now five percent off tell your
friends use this coupon
Everybody!
Big sell!
Do you want the coffee, guys?
Are you here for the...
Are you here for the coffee?
At least my milk and cheese is doing good.
Eighty-two cents.
Ooh.
There you go.
I eventually got there.
Oh, thank God.
At least my water's doing great.
Okay.
My water and cheese.
Eighty.
There you go.
Yay!
Uh, oh, oil.
The oil boom.
It's working.
Okay.
Alright, putting that away.
Tag yourself out of milk.
Oh my god!
I knew it!
Sir, you look like a person that knows your coffee.
You look like a man that loves coffee!
My man!
That's my man right there.
Okay, we need to get rid of that.
And then...
Cheese.
Alright, bring that away.
Sir, are you here for your cereal and water?
Sir, you're one of those people.
Serial and water people.
oh no he's one of them okay let's see 11.98 yay oh my god
we're actually running out of water for once cheese time i
have 4.1 bread
eight nine there you go okay bread time wait do we need more
what do we need more water, cheese.
We always need water and cheese.
Water, cheese, water, cheese.
We'll order water and cheese first.
And then, okay, cheese time.
And then we'll put, yeah, now I can put my cheese on the
floor.
That's okay.
But, oh, oh, I can't sell my cheese on the shelf.
That's so dumb.
like not change my prices and just be like 50 off guys
everything is 50 off from the original prices
guys like i think i saw that in apex where they did like
they did like a huge sale and then they crossed the numbers
out and it was the same price i could do that this sale is
gonna end in five minutes and 30 seconds if you don't act
quick guys there you go all right water and milk are you
paying my cash yeah cheese is too expensive everybody else
liked my cheese you're the only person that didn't like the
cheese don't keep paying your bills i don't need to pay my
bills i need to pay my bills
Duck up Thank you for the super chat Thank you It'll be even
better If don't show the price at all And randomize it as
checkout Got your foot to be an instant
Oh my god Alright Where's the money?
Oh, there's your card Okay, sorry Sorry, my night vision
hasn't kicked in yet Sorry Alright, 38 Uh 850 there you go
one oil that's fine by me 5.99 nice look at that we're doing
so good look at that the kitchen market now dalahala thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you just want to say
you have a cute laugh and thanks for coming thank you thank
you thank you i'm glad you've been enjoying it a hundred and
eighteen dollars profit look at that we're almost at hundred
dollars milk is up milk and eggs are up wait wait how do i
how do i do this milk and okay unit price milk okay i can be
more expensive with milk now okay it went up by how much how
much should it go up by 1.20 so that means i can technically
sell sell it for 4.99 i sell for 4.99 now cereal and bread.
Okay, cereal and bread.
Our OG money makers.
Oh my god.
Milk stocks are going up, guys.
Where were you guys?
Milk stocks is to, we're going to the moon.
We're going to the moon.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe the milk stock.
It's rising.
Okay, where's my cheese?
bought my cheese.
Alright, we're opening.
Ding, ding, ding.
Open time.
I'm saving up for a cashier right now.
Okay, let's see.
We can...
We can buy tea.
That's fine.
Alright, that's like, can be shelved down here, right?
Yeah, tea next to the coffee.
That should make sense.
Nice.
Alright.
Tea.
And then we're gonna make it 6... 6, 32, 7, eight eight
where's eight eight dollars there you go four nine i profit
there you go that should be good profit we're open i am here
to wait can i like explore the place oh i can but i
shouldn't no please i'm sorry i shouldn't explore we don't
have a cashier
$5.99.
Thank you, sir, for supporting your local business.
Thank you.
More boss.
Thank you for the 20.
Get the ships.
Thank you.
Ma'am, are you here?
Oh, my God.
You have a big family, ma'am.
Oh.
Thank you.
The store is happy for your service.
Oh, my God.
Past the night?
Is it past the night tonight for you?
Okay, let's see.
For...
35.
See, milk!
Oh, you heard about the milk boom!
Don't worry, our cows are all raised at a nice, humane farm.
We, we make sure, we make sure they're fed premium grass.
That's why, that's why the milk boom is going up.
Let's see, oil.
Oh, we're running out of coffee.
We're running out of the coffee for the businessmen.
Okay, coffee.
This is expensive fucking coffee but it's okay thanks our
cows our cows live the good life okay guys we have good cows
oh ma'am thank you for taking that water now i can stock
this all right just one bottle of water no problem 47 what
the fuck are you doing with your life all right 20 25 there
you go at least i don't have to oh my god that's a lot of of
caffeine there so are you okay is your life okay are you
going through some crunch work it's too oh you can afford
the coffee but not the tea i see how it is cooking is a
hobby okay baking sorry not cooking baking is a nice hobby
you can't afford baking because you have no joy in your life
if you love having joy you would invest in baking Also,
thank you for shopping at Half Foods.
Thank you.
Please come again.
Please, please come again.
Alright, here you go.
What was that?
Sorry, I meant baking.
Cooking is a good skill.
The clerk that I would avoid at all costs.
You can't avoid me.
I'm losing the manager.
It's too bad.
I run this store.
You know what you're getting.
The milk is too expensive.
Have you, sir, have you not heard about the milk boom?
Have you not heard about the milk boom?
Premium toky.
All right, nice.
are you gonna make pasta without the milk what about the
cream sauce oil oil my biggest oil you'll never fail me you
never disappoint me oil
they'll they'll regret the day when half foods become
two-thirds goods
don't regret it Don't regret pissing me off.
Okay, sir, thank you.
Thank you for shopping at Half Foods.
27.50.
Oh, ma'am.
Would you like a discount?
We're having a sale right now.
0% off.
Don't worry.
Oh, would y'all join the membership?
I forgot about the membership.
Ma'am!
to collect points every purchase you get one point it
doesn't matter how much you buy
if you raise enough points you get a shopping bag what about
donation the dokey points wait what was on top was a flower
oh my god we finally ran out of flower it took so long
because my flower is a little bit overpriced but just a
little bit it's it if you love to cook it's worth it you
love to bake i mean all right nice 100.00 exactly if you get
100 points you get 0.01 discount let's see 92 all right
coffee this woman needs it it's too expensive what you're
gonna have oil you're gonna hurt yourself the food is gonna
stick to your pad if you don't buy my oil all right 16.18
thank you ma'am would you like to kindly donate uh five
dollars to uh the charity for dogs would you ma'am also
would you like to join our membership each point each
purchase equals on one point and when you collect a thousand
points you can have a zero point one point one discount i
don't think she wants to join my my membership guys i don't
don't forget sir would you like to like like would you like
to give some money in the tip jar sir are our shopkeepers
are paid by tips only i'm the only employee
are you tg thank you with the super chat thank you thank you
are you willing to round your your spend to ten dollars to
help your local tomato farm sir would you like to do that
would you like to round your purchase up Would you like to
round your purchase up to $20 to help your local doki?
It's only $5 more.
I didn't think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm surprised none of the boxes outside get stolen.
Because I will know where they live.
They know I'm crazy because I opened right next to the Whole
Foods down the lane.
They don't want to piss off.
the manager that opened a competing store that's more
expensive than whole foods all right nice okay card 22.47
did i run out cheese i can't tell because it's dark but it
saves money no at the close wait is there anybody here i
can't tell there's nobody here right yeah there's nobody
here sorry i'm like i'm like a A blind morad.
I didn't look.
I had to touch everything to know if anybody's here.
Okay, we need cheese and milk.
Oh, there's a cheese boom!
Oh my god.
The cheese boom market, it's here.
This is everything I've been waiting for.
I knew it was gonna show up.
The cheese boom.
We've been preparing for this, guys.
We've been preparing for this Right moment Just put the milk
here for now And then make sure this Box of milk doesn't
spoil The cheese boom What is the boom?
Did I buy more cheese?
I bought, I accidentally bought more cheese But it's okay
We're prepared for the boom Okay How much is cheese?
2.15 What was it before?
Wait, what was it before?
How much did it go up by?
Guys, how much did the cheese go up by?
I don't remember.
Guys!
The marker price was...
Oh, 4.0.
Okay, then it'd be...
it should be five then okay five right no six yeah that
sounds right six dollar cheese cranberry thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you to be honest working for
target they still made us work in the dark when power was
out and the heat and in the heat when our He went out with
no water.
Doki is a great boss.
Oh my god.
Thank god for reminding me.
It's time to turn off the heat as well.
You don't need heat at night.
Guys, just open the door.
The wind.
We don't need heat because we can close the door.
If it's very humid, we can open the door at night.
Or, wait, no, no, no.
Okay, if it's hot, if it's hot.
too hot we open the door so it's cooler with the wind coming
in if it's winter if it's winter we close the door and like
just make sure we don't open the door so the heat will stay
in and then we if it's like too hot we don't need ac we just
keep the door open and then like um at nighttime we
this is it this is this is genius okay we gotta we gotta buy
sugar we don't have sugar yet all right sugar time just
bundle up we'll give you guys jackets just come in to work
with more clothes on if you're too too cold guys we are a
business we want to grow the business guys we're here to
Okay, it's six.
Yeah.
We're here to grow our business.
We need to make sacrifices.
Guys, it's all about sacrifice.
Do you not love half-foods?
Do you want Target to win?
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One cheese, please.
Guys, I can't believe it.
You are willing to let Target win.
Oh, my God.
Guys, you don't want that.
Also, I don't even know if there's been like...
If you guys can even hear the sound.
Have you guys been able to hear the sound this entire time?
the the sound of me restocking okay no you don't hear that
so i've been playing wait yes it has sound wait okay oh i
almost charged this lady 138 dollars yes guys this has sound
okay let me turn up the sound real quick
okay guys let's have like supermarket music in to be more
you know need supermarket music.
Let me...
We need to be more immersed in our supermarket.
Supermarket music.
There we go.
More sounds of the department store.
Alright, what is this?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, it's fine.
I can get fucking copyright claimed again.
There we go.
I got copyright claimed.
for playing Ava Maria.
That's fine.
Here we go.
Does it sound like we're in the supermarket now?
Actually, no.
Maybe not.
Maybe that's not a good idea.
Okay.
Supermarket.
Copyright free.
The church got me, by the way.
Yes.
got me isn't they they they had Jesus actually copyright
claim me oh there you yeah there you this is copyright free
okay wait wait listen on repeat people are gonna go crazy
but it's fine we're gonna listen to this on repeat chat
let's see yep all right here you go there we go this is good
hey hello welcome welcome to half foods it feels like we're
actually at the supermarket guys are you not excited we get
to listen to this yeah that's the stuff that's the
supermarket we've been waiting for no i'm so embarrassed
right now we did not price the milk no that's fine the milk
prices is fine okay maybe not okay maybe 4.50 that's the
lowest i'll go now we're cooking here now we're actually
what do you mean it's It's the cheese boom!
Okay, 5.50.
That's the lowest I'll...
I'll go.
I hope you enjoy your experiences here.
Okay, we need to...
We need to sell...
This man has my entire flower stock now.
Okay.
I need to fucking stock this up.
Bum bum This is the best supermarket Your children cannot
get lost here Do not worry Granberry, thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you I can't handle the no heat
AC I can handle the darkness But this music is gonna make me
Come on strike I can't take it Thank you for the super chat,
thank you, thank you Oh, we need coffee Now we're gonna
listen to this for an hour Strike
No, this is reasonably priced milk.
You can't make me lower my milk costs.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum.
All right, our goal, our goal, guys, is to get level 10 and
hire a minimum wage worker to work here forever.
and listen to this every single day.
That is my goal.
I need a hiring minimum wage worker to stand here for the
rest of their life and listen to this two-minute repeat.
The worst part is that it's like two minutes repeat too.
That's the worst part of it all.
It's not like...
There's no variety.
It's literally two minutes long, and it's just going on
repeat.
I am so dead.
Welcome to hell.
Okay, 14.49.
Nice.
Guys, what happened?
Why do you not want to find cheese?
It's the cheese boom.
The cheese boom.
Here you gave it.
give this super chat thank you thank you Kaz a trip to hell
was never this cheap only at hello it is half foods not
dokey mart's dokey mart's is down the street it's my second
business venture
hello sir what about that cheese sir what about that cheese
this the cheese market is going up there is a cheese
shortage right now in France they're going up going on their
500th strike.
It's their anniversary.
We're striking.
Okay.
Nice.
Powder sugar.
Okay.
41.
58.
52 area.
Wait.
Is it profit?
Guys.
Cheese.
Oh my god.
Why does no one want the cheese?
Is the music not it's the music the music is not inciting a
cheese purchases guys we need we need the music is not
giving me cheese vibes we need better music we need more
cheese music what do i do cheese copyright free right free
music okay cheese copyright copyright free music what do I
get does it sound like cheese I can't tell this is two
minutes long so I don't know supermarket royalty free stock
supermarket why is it so oh hey supermarket stock videos is
there music on that there's supermarket stock videos more
songs more songs okay no that's not copyright free re-upload
sounds for the supermarket oh my god sounds for the
supermarket okay if you're looking for a classic then look
no further this music contains inaudible subliminal
recordings that were intended to increase buyer purchases Oh
my god, the description is perfect.
Guys, it says here that this music contains inaudible,
subliminal recordings that were intended to increase buyer
purchasing at grocery stores.
Customers were influenced to purchase more products as a
result of the brainwave patterns hidden in the musical notes
and the sound composition.
is it?
This will get me all the cheese purchases.
I found it.
Here we go.
Will you buy my cheese now?
We're so immersive.
Guys.
Oh my god.
It makes you want to buy the cheese.
I got it.
super chat super chat now okay 28 51 area all right 36.98 oh
my god look at all these customers it's working it just
works I feel the urge to buy cheese.
Mr. T, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, it should work.
It should work.
There's two more hours.
And the music, it's compelling me.
Thank you for the super chat, Ivan.
Thank you, thank you.
You can't resist.
You can't resist the music.
Come on, come on.
Sir, sir, you know you want.
sir sir the cheese is right there no sir sir we have an hour
left there's still hope someone please
for some reason i'm compelled to send this super chat it's
just thank you with the super chat thank you thank you it
just works it just works guys guys cheese please please we
have five Please come in.
Come in for the cheese.
Please come in.
Come on.
No, that's not the cheese I'm gonna head to the cheese.
Head to cheese.
Yes.
Thank you for the zipper chat.
Thank you.
It works on everything but the cheese.
No!
okay this is a good song though not gonna lie now i know why
people buy more wait is that cheese oh it
worked we did it it just works it just works guys
oh my here take that one cent for free oh my god you deserve
it sir that one cent our first a thousand dollars nika thank
you for the akasupa thank you thank you i don't know what
happened but it happened weird how did i get here mr brookin
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it just
works and look at that My water!
It's gone!
Alright.
And...
Wait, did all the cheese stuff fell down, too?
No, wait, no, it's the same.
Suddenly, I think I wanted to buy cereal.
Wait, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jen, thank you for the super sticker.
Thank you.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, my bread!
Okay, we need bread.
Guys, we did it.
We made our first thousand.
we were here oh my god look at all these items were almost
sold out look at that it works the subliminal messaging i
knew i knew there was science to it
i'm the best employee Burrito, thank you for the magenta
soup, but thank you.
I thought Doki was a gamer, but she's all about the cheese.
I have always been all about the cheese.
I've been cheesing every video game I touch.
Look at that.
I think that subliminal music has worked better for the
water than the cheese.
Not gonna lie.
Please, we're three levels away.
We're three levels away.
Please, bye, and my stuff.
Buy my merch!
Please!
Alright, we need...
Okay.
We need to pay our bills, though.
Bill, bill.
Alright.
I think I can afford...
You know what?
I think I can afford another fridge.
No, no!
I think I can afford!
I think I can afford another license.
What do I?
I need.
Level six.
Peanut butter, flour, olive oil, pasta, rice, and salt.
I have the money.
It's time.
All right.
Guys, one water?
Good choice.
$3 water with your card.
That's good.
All right.
one cent all right we gotta stock it up please we're so
close to peanut butter okay we put peanut butter here and
then we gotta make sure nobody buys peanut butter now okay
seven dollars yeah one milk no problem sir oh thank you for
the exact change all right salt get the salt right here
we're expanding so hard right now look at that and also some
rice some rice with your spaghetti that's right so guys give
me a sec please don't buy my stuff yet four dollars uh nine
dollars there you go guys this is very expensive rice is
important all my stuff here is imported uh from america
I never said where it's important.
Did I say Madagascar?
Peanut oil?
I meant Madagascar city.
I meant Madagascar city, guys.
And did I say like little...
Did I say Italy?
I meant little Italy in New York City.
It is important.
Just not where you think it's important.
Guys, you don't want to support the grandmas in Little
Italy?
Can I agree?
Yeah, I meant the Madagascar movie themed oil.
You know how companies, like, to sell vegetables to kids,
they just put, like, cartoon characters on there to, like,
like there's nothing there's nothing different between the
vegetables it's literally just like like they just slap
shrek there to be make you eat more veggies because they're
like oh my god look this carrot these carrots have shrek's
face on it eat your veggie kids so it's basically like that
I slapped the Madagascar movie it's just marketing nice
there you okay I think it's time I think it's time to change
swap up the music going crazy I think I'm I'm low-key going
crazy with this song so I for the sake of everybody's sanity
I was about to spend money too I was almost about to spend
money the background music is melting my brain do not worry
do not do not worry why i saved this all i was like oh no
i'm about to do retail therapy somebody stop me i i had to i
had to stop myself as well for all of us for all of us it
was for the greater good Let me find better music real fast.
Honestly, I didn't really hear...
Since I generally work in a grocery store.
I feel...
Yeah, I think workers who had to work...
Like the supermarket workers that had to listen to the...
I'm pretty sure they don't change up the songs, right?
At the supermarket.
Or at any targets or whatever.
They don't really change up the song.
So every day you're just listening to the same song.
Over and over and over.
again every single day like i would fucking go crazy oh my
god i i think i would go crazy too okay let me not they
don't oh yeah they do not yeah yeah i'm here for escapism
not bringing you back to hell yes don't worry don't worry
i'm here to help you escape from the torture of wajikiji all
right let's see i need to find there was this channel that i
really like for uh copyright free music but i need to find
it again i need to i need to find it again guys just give me
a sec uh god damn it where is it it's one of my favorite
like background uh bgms uh place because it had It was
copyright free, and this was really nice.
It was, like, a Korean channel, too.
I just need to find a channel again, because it's been a
while.
Where is it?
No!
We can't go crazy!
We can't...
No, it's not Dova Syndrome.
It's like a...
It's like a Korean...
It's a Korean one, and it's really nice.
Oh, wait, did they change the...
Wait, is it this one?
Where is he?
Free music?
No, it's not this one.
Oh.
What was it?
I'm trying to remember the...
The...
Yeah, there was like this really good...
Really good Korean channel for copyright BGM music.
I'm trying to like remember...
What it was called.
Oh, is it this one?
I'm gonna try this one.
Is it this channel?
No, it wasn't this channel.
it was not this way it was like a blue it was a blue uh icon
it was a blue icon not this one
it was so cute too they had they had such cute music oh i
found it i found it guys is one of my favorite beat it's
called this is the one i use um it's this is the bgm place i
use usually their stuff is like super cute and they have a
lot i love using this well there you go now we can be less
insane all right here you go but um but um but um but um but
um but um now i can be a Be stuck in a cage for a little bit
longer.
I...
Sanity restoring.
I can work in a cage a little longer.
Is that great?
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Used to work in electronic slot and the song playlist was
bad.
But during Christmas, it was literally torture.
Mariah Carey's.
The thing is, there's not a lot of Christmas music, too.
Especially for one that you have to do it for hours and
hours straight.
There's not enough music to keep up for Christmas season.
There's like what?
Two hours max of songs.
I have one for Christmas is you.
Alright, let's see.
uh wait oh i'm giving wait whoops sorry this is not that i
don't know why i tried to give you like 16 there give me a
sec please be patient i'm stupid uh there you go that was
the longest 47 cents ever coffee i'm extra coffee no i have
extra tea all right please i'm almost level eight
Please buy from my store.
I need more shoppers.
Sir, no!
Please, I need to be level 10!
Please!
Don't you want me to hire a teenager and pay the minimum
wage, sir?
And give them real life working experience, sir!
Think of the minimum wage teenager Alright Serial Nope They
need this job to buy their graphics card Alright Nice Let's
see 30 at 251 Whoops Nice Serial to real Sorry That's too
real.
Please let me employ this minimum wage teenager for the
first work experience.
Think of the teenager.
Okay, $2.41 cents.
There you go.
What's your money?
$4.
Bam.
I'm not.
No one wants to work here We're the lights You don't need
lights Use your eyes You have eyes We have built in night
vision Wait I've messed up my fucking playlist already
You don't need it We have built in night vision Do we?
Yes we do The longer we work in the dark, the better evolved
we are.
Thank you, ma'am, for thinking about the teenagers and
letting me hire one for minimum wage.
Oh, yeah, it's better to hide prices in darkness, too.
That's the best part.
If they can't see the price, they don't know it's
overpriced.
we are a store that cares about our customers vision if you
guys don't know some people are living with like um
sensitive eyes we are here for those people it's all about
the oh natural
we're the oh natural store all right oh no no the oil not
the oil sale okay we'll make it for dollars profit no oh
wait that's not the oil that's not the oil i work with oh no
it is
it's it's my brain working for I'm way
I love it here Jockey please Z thank you for the Akasupa
Thank you thank you It's my birthday day So I want to give
you something back Thank you for making a smile Jockey Thank
you I'm glad you've been enjoying your time here Happy
birthday to you Happy birthday It's hard to sing with this
song In the background At birthday, dear Ebergo, at birthday
to you
All right, is there anything else we need?
I feel like we have, okay, rice, oh, olive oil.
Okay, we'll grab olive oil.
We'll grab another cup of flour.
And then what else?
What else do we need?
Okay, do we have shells for it?
Okay, we have shells for it.
We have two, three.
Okay, and then pasta, spaghetti.
We're so close to level A.
Okay, spaghetti.
Spaghetti.
Somebody would need the spaghetti.
Give me a sec.
I need to put down supreme flour.
Spaghetti.
Okay, market price.
I'm going to do 7.50.
And then...
No, no.
Do not buy the average cost.
I need profit!
7.7.
There we go.
Butter, butter.
Nice.
Thank you for blood.
We have new flour.
Would you like new flour?
Alright.
37.0.
Oh, 0.5.
Do you really care about that five sensor?
God damn it.
You and your fucking...
$100 bill for one fucking flower.
Milk!
We need milk!
milk nice okay milk oh shit wait i bought well i forgot
about the oil i forgot about the oil please no my milk can
my milk get run over by a car i'm asking for scientific
purposes all right nice all right okay 90 cents guys we're
almost there we're almost at level eight plus five Guys,
we're going to hit the big eight.
The big eight.
Two dollars.
Oh my god, I'm so fast at this now.
Can I upgrade my store now?
Management Grove.
Oh my god, section two.
We don't need to expand, though, I feel like.
I think we're cozy, honestly.
Like, we're cozy here.
What does expanding do for us anyway?
Like, it's not like more people are going to show up.
Like...
if you think about it like I don't think more people is just
gonna show up to my store oh shit I'm running out of coffee
now okay give me a sec okay I need to buy coffee where's
coffee dark roast okay there you go stop stop sir stop
coffee's coming ah there's too many boxes
let's see 31.53 guys don't worry when the teenager is here
i'll start throwing the boxes away i just don't have time
right now we're just gonna stockpile some it's it's called
the environment we're gonna reuse resell we're gonna sell
the boxes people we want to use the boxes to carry their
stuff home you know don't you know like at costco there's
like a ton of boxes that you can just, like, pick up.
That's what it is.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's called saving the environment.
You guys wouldn't understand.
You guys don't love the environment as much as me.
Oh my god, look at that.
We're almost level 9.
Wait, do you want a card?
Okay, card.
Please, all I want to do is just hire...
Why do you have to be level 10 to hire?
a minimum wage worker.
I don't understand.
Like, I'm literally giving him free money.
I'm a good boss, too.
I'm a good boss.
Let me hire him.
Oh, the olive oil!
Oh, no!
Stop buying the olive oil!
I'm not making profit!
Stop!
I forgot the olive
oil Okay Alright the last level For the last level We're
gonna have a big sell But for now we need to make money Stop
Stop buying the olive No I lost all the oil Too many people
took advantage Of the poor business woman Okay, oil.
I need to restock it, apparently.
Okay, I lost weight.
Just go out of business.
Don't anybody think of the fucking poor businesswoman.
Oh, my God.
My water.
I need water, too.
Okay.
Please just wait at the cashier.
I'm getting water.
It's called tax loss.
I'm sorry.
Give me a second.
There's so many boxes.
Okay, 14.
Alright.
Cash, $1.
Nice.
Okay, there we go.
We're just gonna keep stocking boxes here.
No, nobody's buying my cheese anymore.
The cheese market crashed.
Oh, I can't believe we lived long enough to see the cheese
market crash.
crashing.
Oh, wait.
I didn't see you there.
Guys, it's not too dark here, okay?
I just had my eyes closed.
It's okay.
No, I can totally see.
My eyes were just closed.
Lord, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gotta manifest your destiny and get more oil.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
The cheese bubble burst.
How will France sustain themselves now?
What else are they going to export?
France the city in America of course.
I'm talking about the city of France in America.
Where's your hand?
There it is.
Oh it's nine.
Do you have anything you want to sell?
Okay.
card okay nice we're almost halfway there little friends
paris texas exactly somebody understands how much that 372
dollar profit next nice nice nice nice nice nice nice even
with the the oil situation we did it oh shit okay um i what
what Okay, um, okay, guys, I, what, what do I need to
restock?
Okay, peanut butter, peanut butter, coffee, um, rice, rice
went up, oh my god, who cares about fucking, oh, pasta, I
need pasta, pasta, uh, what else, no, not the stock, salt
market no but how much not the salt market it's fine we'll
keep it there i don't remember what else i have to stock up
okay spaghetti oh the oil i need to remember the oil that's
fine and then rice okay rice is up now we don't it's okay uh
this is stuff i still have uh you know we'll find we'll keep
this and then coffee okay restock restock spot and the
non-restock uh peanut butter and then we need we need pasta
we need pasta oil okay pasta where's pasta pasta where's
pasta where's my fucking pasta all right pasta And normal
oil.
I'm going to live like this.
I don't have my minimum wage worker.
What am I supposed to do?
You think I'm throwing this out myself?
That's what the teenagers are for.
Oh, I already have.
Fuck you.
I already bought pasta!
Okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
It's okay.
Here you go.
we're fine.
We're fine.
Is there anything else we're missing?
What else are we missing?
My back stock is insane.
Flower!
Okay.
Flower.
Alright.
Bam.
Is there anything else?
Please.
It can go higher.
higher.
Sugar.
Where is this sugar?
Okay, yeah, sugar.
Okay, we have sugar.
We're sugar.
Okay, here.
Is there anything else?
We don't have enough.
Okay, we can, we'll put room temperature sugar until... Oh,
I have an idea.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
I have an idea.
Do I have a milk box?
Do I have a milk box anywhere?
Okay.
See, we'll put the eggs in there when we have enough room.
Not buying another fridge.
That's too much money.
Oh, wait, that's used.
Okay, this can go higher.
There we go.
We're ready.
We're ready for business.
We've restocked, I think.
Okay, I'm going to double check.
Oil, water, peanut butter, flour.
Yeah, we stocked everything.
There you go.
Guys, stop judging me.
I'm just I'm just a single parent to doky amber does to try
to make things work at half foods like people don't care
about what it looks like on the inside it's all about the
food it's all about the food
It's all about the food.
I have quality food.
Flower.
I almost...
Oh god.
This can be higher.
No!
There you go.
Go to you guys.
Nice.
Okay.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
43 we're almost the moment we hit level 9 we're gonna go on
a big sale guys we're gonna go on a big sale speed run to
level 10 25.50 all right here you go this is good this is
good we need someone to buy more on on this episode on
hoarders we are toky with boxes this is not a choice It's
not a choice cruising.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not a choice.
It's a problem.
And I'm willing to admit it.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
19.
Nice.
Plus five.
Please.
We need you to get rid of the cheese and the milk.
So I can put the eggs.
The eggs are at room temperature later.
please my eggs are on room temperature someone please take
think of the eggs you never know exactly you never know when
you need a box exactly now we're thinking this is what
happens when your streamer isn't forklift certified look i'm
almost close to a thousand oh my god look at all the stuff
she bought and she paid an exact that's the customer i like
oh my god it's happening guys we have eggs finally there we
go oh my god we finally have eggs it's happening it's
fucking happening oh my god imagine my charger like 150
dollars okay we need water you ever oh my god did you guys
see that tweet of like this uh manager in in japan that like
accidentally ordered like 999 unigiri's and he's like please
it expires in one day we need people to Onigiri's!
That's gonna be me.
I'm gonna accidentally use my entire savings and order like
999 eggs.
Oh shit.
Give me a sec, lady.
I'm trying to calculate.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for buying our stuff.
Yeah, they actually did because it went viral because people
were like, why the fuck do you I have so much eggs.
Not eggs.
Onigiri.
Like people around.
Like people in the area.
Just went and helped this poor man.
Who accidentally ordered 999.
Onigiri's.
Alright.
I'm gonna accidentally like.
Buy more stock of things.
I never needed.
Oh wait.
7.
I see 7.
Okay.
Do I have bread?
There must be.
Do I have.
I have cheese.
Wait I have cheese.
I know I have cheese.
There we go.
And then flour.
Okay, now I already have flour.
Oil.
Nice.
Oh, I can rotate it!
Oh my god!
Oh, it changes everything.
This changes everything.
I can rotate.
No!
Wait, there's stuff in this box.
Wait, there was stuff in this box.
There we go.
Okay, there's something.
nice i had enough time 19.5 okay water okay spaghetti
spaghetti do i have do i need to put more flour no flour is
good what about salt why does no one want the salt you need
to season your food please think about your seasoning 30.
what is that exact change.
Okay.
Peanut butter and bread.
Do I have peanut butter?
Do I need coffee?
Oh, okay.
Coffee.
Okay.
Nice.
Water.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry, sir.
37.4.
Nice.
Alright, we need we need peanut butter and bread.
I'm a little concerned that my bread has been on that shelf
for like four days now, but it's okay.
It's okay.
People love it when it's a little If it's too soft, then
it's for pussies.
Where's the door?
Everybody likes it when the bread is a little hard.
Guys.
Okay.
I think.
Where's the cashier entrance area?
There.
Alright.
23.
Nice.
Okay, here we go.
1, 2, 3, 50, 60, 70, 80.
There we go.
What did you buy?
I can't tell.
What was that?
I see our items.
7, 25, 40, 45.
There we go.
Where's your card?
Okay, there we go.
92!
Holy shit!
2.
there nice oh we got a big spender here providing for his
family 30.65 oh my god we're almost at level nine what is it
wait lady shop is done oh you're just gonna come here the
store is close you're just gonna come here and fucking
fucking talk about how fucking expensive my store is It's
fucked up, man.
Wait, I can keep making sales.
There's more people coming in.
Oh my god, he bought all the oil.
The oil is still ready.
All right, now we can end the day.
How much money?
Products found expensive, 31.
Well, we don't care about you.
no no my cheese okay my spaghetti is okay what is this is
bread okay oh it's okay it's okay we're gonna stack this
nice and tall there we go we're gonna make sure no what is
the physics okay you know what that's fine okay that's fine
it's fine people can still walk around it uh do i need flour
i do there you go it's okay as long as people can walk
around it's fine okay uh do i need pasta no wait is this not
pasta what is this what am i carrying Is this flower?
Did I run out of flower?
Oh, I did.
Oh my god, people love flower.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna have our biggest cell.
The moment I can put this away.
Okay, we need to have a...
People still need to be able to access the oil.
This is the second part of the gameplay.
I'm really paying you to...
Fine!
fine there you go that's how much that's worth thank you
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you that's a
that's a market value for me to throw away my box it's like
the recycling fee you know like when you recycle a box you
get paid like um an amount for recycling for bringing your
recycle blows over.
Yeah, like when you recycle bottles and fucking cardboard
boxes.
Oh, yeah, like in Germany, there's like these like machines.
I was like watching YouTube short and there's like this
machine that like lets you, that like basically if you don't
recycle it, you have to give the money.
You have to like, there's like a fee to pay if you don't
recycle.
But then if you recycle, they give you money.
Please the box in the living room.
Oh, yeah, dinner fee.
There you go.
Here's one box.
Thank you.
I'm going to super chat.
Okay.
That is...
What was that?
Wait, what is this?
I don't remember what I have in my shop.
It's so long.
Oh, cereal.
It was the cereal.
Cereal.
We need more oil.
What do I need?
There's too many items.
I'm getting confused.
Cereal.
Okay, we got cereal.
Do we have sugar?
We have sugar.
I'm getting too confused.
There's too many items in my fucking...
Okay.
I feel like there was something at the bottom there.
What the fuck was there?
I have boxes.
Okay.
There we go.
Please throw another one out.
Here for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Box disposal fee.
Thank you.
Thank you with the aquasuit.
Okay.
Fine.
You get two boxes.
Alright.
What else in my flower was at the bottom?
I already have flower.
Do I have two flowers?
I have two flowers.
I think that was it, right?
I think that's everything.
That should be everything.
I'm pretty sure.
Wait, I need to put more cheese.
I'm running out of cheese.
Wait, is it cheese?
Is that cheese?
Oh, my eggs!
I forgot.
Oh, wait, no.
I already have eggs.
Okay, cheese.
I need cheese.
Alright.
Cheese.
There we go.
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
do something wild here.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna go our biggest sell yet.
Okay, $2.95.
Okay, $3.
Alright, we're gonna make it so that we only make $1 profit
so we can speedrun to level 10.
I'm...
Fuck.
We're gonna speedrun.
We're gonna speedrun this shit now.
Okay, let's see.
Five.
There we go.
Please.
Buy my stuff.
It's so cheap now.
It's such a steal.
Buy my...
Oh my god, I was $10.
Oh my god, my shit was so expensive.
Holy fuck.
No wonder people didn't want to fucking shop here.
Biggest cell yet!
Bye, bye, bye!
Four.
Okay.
Um, six.
Please!
I'm begging you to rob me at this point!
This is highway robbery!
Oh, I need more flower.
Wait, do I have flower in here?
There's so many things.
I'm literally paying you guys to fucking rob me.
I bought the wrong flower.
Sorry, the flower was red.
There's too many flowers.
Okay.
there we go we're gonna put this here we have our own stack
now i'm gonna forget what i do have i'm pretty sure come all
right carl thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
i'm robbing your store please put me out of business i'm
letting you put me out of business just get me out out of
here whoa whoa whoa i'm not making you put that me out of
business that easily seven dollars all right i need to get
that sugar in here oh nice okay i honestly i don't i don't
know there's too many items here why did i order so much
peanut butter why do i have so much peanut butter
Wait, did I actually pay her less?
No!
Guys, please, I didn't mean actually steal from me.
I...
Yes, please.
Please come back and give me back the money.
Please, I'm just a local business person.
Wow, I think it was this.
okay and then oil oh no water okay spaghetti oh please i'm
i'm getting overwhelmed right now
liquid thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you akasupa
for your taste in dog breeds please give them pet for the
random interest thank you thank you for the akasupa how do
you say it's too expensive You're literally there's prop
there.
I'm literally asking you to steal from me like
This is almost the same price as whole foods.
Oh my god.
What do I need to restock?
350 Okay $20 Oh, that is a lot of stuff you're buying Water
Okay.
Water is done.
Cheese is done.
This flower.
Oh, no one wants this flower.
No one likes that flower.
Okay.
Coffee.
Okay, we need coffee.
What do we need?
Coffee.
Ah, tea.
Tea.
Um, please, sir.
Wait a minute.
I'm getting overwhelmed.
Tea.
Sugar.
Uh.
Yeah, that's it!
Oh my god, that's- Okay.
Check out.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay, I need- I need a sock up.
What is this?
Sugar!
Okay, get in here.
Box, get in here!
Pasta!
Sir, please!
I'm sorry!
13.6.
Alright, one customer, one restock.
T.
Nice, we're restocking everything.
and then coffee.
Guys, do you guys want to look more?
Look at the beautiful things we have?
Do you want to look more?
Do you want to shop more?
We got a recent restock!
this is too big of a sale.
I was not... I was not made for all this sale.
Okay.
Eggs.
Oh, what am I missing?
Um, where's my eggs?
We had sugar all this long?
Okay.
Oh, long.
I already had, I already had sugar.
Okay.
Uh, the flower.
We need the other flower.
We need the man flower that's what wait no that's pasta
there you go okay where's the rich man flower water oh
there's too much of a line oh my god this is not going so
well guys okay one dollar nice uh card 19.
i liked it better when my store was inaccessible
my store was harder to afford okay let's see 48 uh please
stop buying everything please i don't have enough free stock
Please!
Ah, what's this?
Flower!
Oh, let's just put in two flowers.
I don't need all that flower.
Yeah, more sugar.
More sugar.
We don't need all that.
What's this?
Is this salt?
What is this?
What am I holding?
This is peanut butter.
Okay, peanut butter is here now.
Okay.
25.3.
Please, we're so close.
We're halfway to level 10.
We're so close to level 10.
18.05.
Is that cash?
Okay, 73.
Oh, that's not...
No, that's not right.
Okay.
Uh, $2.
Anyone want more stuff?
where's the restock I don't know you go here do I have more
items what is this peanut butter one peanut butter do I have
anything else in the corner I don't think so we're good
we're good 16 it's fine yay 45 here you go we're so many
people that want to shop one dollar nice is that it is that
everybody oh my god is that it am i free no one's like so
many boxes just thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you holy fuck okay
all right this is fine this is this is fine This is
absolutely fine.
Okay.
Serial.
Um, what do we need?
Um, do we have the red pasta?
Red pasta.
Sugar.
Wait, we have too much sugar now.
Bottled water.
Oh my god, there's nothing left in my fridge!
Bottled water cheese.
You know what?
I'm adding two of each.
i'm adding two of each i maxed it out okay uh okay we're
gonna get rid of okay we're gonna restart from one okay two
two two two two two okay all right first two rows we've done
the first two rows okay okay and then two two two two all
right okay okay we're good all right and then the last two
two two two two two
There we go.
Okay, we're fine.
This is good.
This is so helpful now.
We're okay.
We're almost at level 10, guys!
Flower.
Okay, that is going here.
And then milk.
Alright.
Milk at the bottom.
Alright, and then.
And then.
Here's our oil.
All right, well, yay!
That is how it feels to work at Dollar Tree.
Thank you for the super chat.
Okay, we're gonna put, like, unopened ones here.
Okay, flower.
All right, flower goes here.
That's an empty box, right?
Yeah, it is.
It's empty.
Okay, milk.
Okay, we're gonna put, like, the unopened ones here, so I
know it's unopened.
We have a system.
We have a system now.
Guys.
This is our system.
It's gonna work.
Okay, cereal.
Like, customers don't care about what it looks like, okay?
Customers do not care.
As long as they can get their daily necessities.
That's all that matters.
Okay.
flower okay we have an open flower okay salt there you go
all right it's fine where am i oh my god i teleported right
in there all right rice restock central uh oil oh wait no no
no no no no no no It's had to be unopened.
This other oil.
Okay, the other oil we don't need yet.
Coffee.
Okay.
We don't need a storage room.
We do not need the extra space.
We have all the necessary space we need.
It's fine.
Okay, peanut butter.
Peanut butter goes here.
this is all the space we need it works it just works it just
works okay and then we'll put the cereal here and then the
cheese goes here thank you with a super chat thank you thank
you everything just works who the fuck okay here we go all
right and then you don't what big customers can come in
right now i don't care
okay eggs all right eggs time nice all right don't talkie
please we need money we need to make money i can't spend all
my time restocking shows guys i can't waste my time
restocking shows guys We need to make money!
Look, he's happy with his one box of sugar!
Alright, I love having my eggs in the sun for like five
minutes.
That sounds ideal.
Please release me from the easiest box.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
And that's bread.
All right, here we go.
We have, it's like Costco.
You guys always wanted a Costco.
It's, is it like Costco, guys?
It almost feels just like Costco.
Okay.
Of all these boxes, we're like Costco.
Okay, $30.
uh 20.
okay we can restock where am i okay we need wait what was
over there coffee where's my coffee guys give me a sec i
know i have another box of coffee somewhere
guys give me a sec i'm trying to find my box of coffee it's
in this pile extra there we go there we go there's my extra
coffee there you go don't worry guys are we stock
it's not falling apart it's a system it's a system one box
please does thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
okay 80 uh four even okay david doge is like we have a
problem problem.
Even he's acknowledging that there's something wrong.
Okay, don't worry, it's 6.6.
Alright, we're good, we're good.
1, 2, uh, 95 milk.
Okay, 3.5.
This is still working well, I see.
It is!
peanut butter.
I know I had a lot of peanut butter.
Where's my peanut butter?
Okay.
That's flour.
Where did all my peanut butter go?
Okay.
Where did y'all go?
I'm gonna put this away though.
Oh.
Okay.
I can restock the water.
Uh.
And the milk.
You all can put all that milk away.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
I know I bought more.
It's okay.
We're almost at level 10.
We're almost at level 10, guys.
Serial.
Someone just bought one cereal.
That's okay.
You do you.
Rice.
Oh my god.
Please.
My father.
Please Please go down
That's okay, that's okay.
We're almost at level 10 We're almost there Yeah, six we did
it We did it we can hire our middle wage teenager.
Oh my god, I need to pay my bills too Okay, where are you?
Hiring.
We did it!
Do you try?
I just need a stock.
Stock, stock, stock.
Oh my god, it's finally here.
It's finally here.
Everything we worked for.
It's here.
Oh my god.
We did it.
this work for me yes keep working I what do I need a stock
for just put more bread I don't care at this point do I need
eggs I think I need eggs don't worry everything's fine milk
I think we need more milk right yeah we need more milk
Now I can do what I've always wanted to do.
Start sacking this better.
Now I have more time for what I'm actually passionate about.
Okay, okay.
TM, because I don't want to get sued after OA1 box.
You know what?
In celebration, we can turn on the lights now.
Rejoice, everybody.
Today is a celebration.
The celebration.
We can turn on the lights.
Go, Jerry.
Wait, is that Elon Musk?
Before he invented.
Before he was a rich kid.
The king was.
my cashier.
This is it.
Announcement!
Announcement.
We have decided.
The company has decided to get rid of all natural light and
decide to cater to the to the light people.
We have decided to cater for the people that have been
demanding for lights.
So I apologize to all the lights and folks out there it was
just more money like we just there was just more people that
are not light sensitive so we just cater for more money we
sold out all in all ever since i got my minimum wage
teenager we sold out
um mr broken bond thank you thank you with a super chat uh i
need to make some artwork of doki trying to juggle the box
with that check out it's fine i did it we did it guys oh i
ran out of turnip oil oh no now i can put more boxes away we
did it everybody oh my god we finally did it i had a dream
to open the best whole whole foods out there and i think i
did it i think i made it
job i think it was a super chat thank you thank you you know
i think that is a good time i think i think this is a good
way to to call it for this game i i think i think we made a
lot of progress you know in general i honestly think we did
really good today i think we did chee chees everybody chees
not gonna lie honestly think my best
oh my god oh i had to leave like three times in anxiety what
do you mean it was perfect i think i knew how to run a store
i think i knew how to run a perfect grocery market um uh
denlin thank you in the super chat thank you thank you i
just posted your situation is still not as bad as mine
devlin thank you for the super chat thank you thing what do
you mean what what do you mean by that what the did you do
to your store holy i thought you met in game bro
look i have in-game problems this is irl problems oh my god
bro are you okay Are you okay, man?
For those who know what the fuck he sent, this is...
Oh, shit, wait.
This is what he sent me.
Like.
I thought you meant in-game.
Oh, my God.
This is too real.
Too real.
Oh, my God.
gotten tm thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
you made a hill of boxes this is what you made thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you uh ma'am corporal
corruption as fine is for real though nice work boss thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you um uh but yeah
that was fun that was really fun uh not gonna lie i feel
like this is a game you can easily just autopilot to and
just like like like uh like seven hours can easily pass
through just playing this game because it's such a it's such
an autopilot game that i feel like you can easily just have
seven hours disappear so fast if you just play it non-stop
yeah it's just fun i had a lot of fun yeah i had um i had a
lot of fun playing it uh golden dragon thinking with super
chat thank you thank you at least you're not like asman gold
trash everywhere thinking with super chat thing thing you've
not seen xqc's room that man had next to his like exposed
gpu like i mean like he had like months old chicken um like
underneath his desk i was there when i watched his live
stream of him trying to build his pc that shit was scary
like he like he like sat on a chair made of pepsi boxes or
was it coke boxes one or the other This man is a millionaire
and he fucking sat on a chair made of coke boxes Like what
like coca-cola Oh my god, bro, that shit is insane.
Oh my god
Oh yeah, yeah
what do you mean I actually I actually go outside my room
and that's the extent for what for a bit all right guys I'm
gonna call it here everybody I hope you guys had a fun time
hanging out with me tomorrow is another rest day and um I'm
gonna be doing getting a lot of work done today and tomorrow
because I need to figure out who's gonna be joining Amalie
and I for the for our game but yeah thank you guys i had a
great time um uh saucy thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you as a person who was pc tech remind me to never
watch xuc the stories i'm hearing man thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you thank you lali thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you all right guys i'm
calling here everybody as always everyone stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and if you stay up from me head to ben because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys Bye!